I think these questions your honor hi
I'm Lucy Lange
Lucy's a former prosecutor for the
Manhattan DA's office in the current
director of the Institute for innovation
prosecution at John Jay College of
Criminal Justice today I'll be breaking
down more clips from film and TV about
the courtroom gag order damages his
wallings personal emails detailing
Affairs she had with Wall Street
executives were included in the leak yes
correct
Jesus Christ call search Garrett I'm not
scheduled a hearing misuse should be
sanctioned and barred from speaking to
the press there are various strategies
that lawyers use to try to influence a
jury or a judge outside of the four
corners of the record of a trial her
television appearance was a calculated
and unfounded attack on my clients
reputation I was simply answering
questions it was a wide-ranging
interview you called my client a rapist
you can understand why the judge would
be concerned about that leaking into the
jury's impartiality I don't want this
thing tried in the press I'm issuing a
gag order
there'll be no discussion to this case
over the airwaves in print online
anywhere a jury is not permitted to be
influenced by outside inputs including
the media no judge should want a case to
be tried in the press this is similar to
what a lawyer might do in the courtroom
when they say something that they know
is not permissible and the judge will
strike from the record but the lawyer
also knows that once the jury has heard
it even if they're told to disregard it
it'll be in the back of their mind I
resent that
so do I the gag order stands catching a
witness and a lie Chicago justice I'd
like to call your attention to the
afternoon of July 11th were you in the
Inglewood neighborhood that day could be
specifically at the home of your cousin
a boy named Andre Williams I don't
remember but you do remember changing
into some of Andres clothes around that
time right but you do remember being
there now I use all these questions
every witness who takes a stand in a
criminal case is under oath which means
they're obligated to tell the truth I
got a choice not uncommon in real life
like in this clip for a witness to
respond repeatedly by saying I don't
know
or I don't recall I'll remember can't
say for sure judge I'd like to show the
witness what's being offered as people's
exhibit 1 all right
you ever seen that particular gun before
no with permission from the court a
lawyer can give things that are in
evidence to a witness on the stand and
ask them to demonstrate however in the
case of a firearm as a general matter it
would be given to a courtroom bailiff
who would be asked to make sure that it
was unloaded or make sure that thing's
not loaded and no circumstances would a
witness on the stand be asked to do that
and what about the magazine clips empty
too
now the magazine release on this gun
it's inoperable but you knew that
because this is your gun that's a pretty
slick move from this lawyer that's why
you had to smack the handle a few times
to get the mag to release just like you
did four months ago when you loaded this
same gun open fire on a group of gang
rivals killing a ten year old girl in
the process you making all this stuff
even if a witness were caught in a lie
the lawyer would ultimately save that
point for their summation rather than
make that point during the examination
of the witness you know what I'm out of
here
the people move to dismiss all charges
against Chris Stackhouse it's not
permissible for a witness at their own
discretion to just get up and walk off
the stand arrest this man for the murder
of Laura Haley
never seen it happen that in the course
of a trial a lawyer moves in front of
everyone in the courtroom to have
someone on the stand arrested for new
crimes sometimes you have to make a
wrong turn before you find your way
possible witness
law and order SVU I don't want to do
this Commission to treat the witness as
hostile your honor
permission granted proceed you must
answer the question this miss Harper
when a lawyers own witness isn't
responding to questions the judge can
grant that lawyer permission to treat
the witness as hostile
that means the lawyer has been given
permission to ask leading questions of
the witness as you would on
cross-examination
you heard the defendants voice in your
house you said you heard his voice in
your house that's why you're hesitant to
identify him now because if you were
wrong then you might be wrong again now
leading questions though have to be in
the form of a question if someone was
there than that with me that means he
killed her is that what you were about
to say judge let me rephrase so this
lawyer who's repeatedly making
speculative statements that means he
killed her is that what you were about
to say is entitled to make those kind of
inquiries but they have to be done in a
form of a question is there a question
anywhere here such as isn't it right
that if he killed her then you killed
her
question mark role reversal Ghostbusters
- so you were just trying to help out
how about a friend who was bright who
was a scare - objection - when you're
scared jack shines no he goes there was
no you won't and enormous action what is
the witness doing here the lawyer should
always be the one asking the questions
where the person on the stand is feeding
the questions or commentary to the
witness the opposing counsel should
definitely object objection your honor
and the objection should be sustained
save witness preparation Seinfeld on the
afternoon of September 10th you received
a phone call did you not phone call yes
a phone call from who
from me from you lawyers are permitted
to prepare their witnesses before trial
and in fact it's a best practice to give
your witness adequate preparation it's
endlessly surprising to me though that
no matter how many times you prepare a
witness there's no accounting for what
someone remembers or says in the moment
what was the question that said I think
that Newman's reaction is a little bit
over the top admissions on the stand
from MADtv the defendant is a flight
risk your honor I could be another
country this afternoon if I wanted to I
got friends who can create false
passports one of the reasons that people
who are charged with crimes are
discouraged from speaking in court is
because anything they say on the record
can be used against them yapple mr.
Henry right now you're only being
charged with armed robbery even if it is
an acknowledgement of other uncharged
crimes like here
motion to dismiss Erin Brokovich and I
have here 84 motions to strike in both
civil and criminal matters the parties
have an opportunity to file a motion to
dismiss on the grounds that the
complaint itself is legally inadequate
it is the order of this court that each
of the 84 motions to strike and demers
are denied once a motion to dismiss has
been denied negotiations often start in
earnest 20 million dollars is more money
than these people have ever dreamed of
see now that could be off first of all
since the demur we have more than 400
plaintiffs and let's be honest we all
know they're more out there 20 million
dollars isn't when you split it between
them before you come back here with
another lame ass offer I want you to
think real hard about what your spine is
worth mr. Walker or what you might
expect someone to pay you for your
uterus miss Sanchez the majority of
civil cases don't go to trial often
they're resolved after negotiations with
a plea so that everyone can cut their
losses and go home rather than risk the
very high stakes of a trial and
ultimately a much greater settlement
your calculator and you multiply that
number by a hundred anything less than
that is a waste of our time throwing the
book at someone from crime story they
probably planted it investigating tag
least length to the KGB KGB
well it's strictly speculation the word
on the street is that that Lee is
selling nuclear secrets to the Russians
I mean I don't not true it is but your
honor the man's a liar that is the
complete lie your honor do I have to
suffer these indignities right here in
the halls of Justice the actor playing
the lawyer is actually my dad you still
got a child remember a lawyer is
permitted to refer to a witness lying
but not to call a witness a liar if a
lawyer were to actually throw a book or
anything else at a witness is a complete
lie they would likely be held in
contempt and if a witness were to throw
anything back at a lawyer or anyone else
in the courtroom proceedings would
likely stop partager thank you your
honor
mandatory sentencing for the people this
is happening all over the country
low-level nonviolent crimes that trigger
disproportionate mandatory minimum
sentences
and I'm part of the problem
what is unusual is that the judge while
he's pronouncing the sentence is
speaking out in opposition to it this
judge and for the people is reflecting a
sentiment that is increasingly part of
the criminal justice reform movement in
this country which is that mandatory
minimum sentencing is an outdated
approach to crime reasonable doubt the
practice you know that 90 something
percent of all defendants are guilty
think about it by the time they get the
trial they've been judged guilty many
times a lawyer is not permitted to offer
statistics that are not in evidence
closing statements are reserved for the
facts and evidence and the law I think
he's guilty but in this country we don't
take away a man's freedom and the
possibility of guilt you have to find
guilt beyond all reasonable doubt
while the lawyer is right that if the
jury has any doubt they must acquit
because his client is presumed innocent
it is bad practice for him to bring in
his own perspective on his clients guilt
or innocence
I'm sure it's how I'm not supposed to
say that but I think he did it
courtroom conduct Kramer vs Kramer we
were married a year before the baby and
then seven years after that so you were
a failure at the one most important
relationship in your life just overruled
the witness's opinion on this is
relevant it might be appropriate to ask
a witness whether in their own view
something had been a failure I was not a
failure Oh what are you gonna do a
success the marriage ended in divorce I
think that this rather nasty line of
inquiry is unfair the question about a
relationship being a failure is kind of
a subjective one are you a failure and
it's not clear exactly why her view of
who failed is what matters here
I consider it less
probably the line of inquiry would have
been stopped earlier when it became
clear that there was a difference of
opinion about what it meant for the
relationship to have been a failure
her ex-husband in the courtroom trying
to convey something subtly to her might
sway her answer and a judge if they
noticed it might respond by stopping
their subtle communication custody
hearings big little lies there's nothing
preventing opposing parties from
speaking to each other off the record
during a custody hearing at the end of
the day we are still family
of course they should bear in mind that
things that are said can be used by one
party against the other this is awfully
different from when we last saw Meryl
Streep in a custody hearing and Kramer
vs Kramer probably 30 years ago and in
that case - she was communicating with
someone off the record we're not family
mary-louise irrelevant evidence
Southpark ladies and gentlemen this is
Chewbacca Chewbacca is a Wookiee from
the planet Kashyyyk
he's using the Chewbacca defense why
would it look an eight-foot-tall wookie
want to live on Endor with a bunch of
two-foot tall Ewoks that does not make
sense but more importantly you have to
ask yourself what does this have to do
with this case nothing objection on the
ground of relevance the evidence about
Chewbacca here is entirely irrelevant if
you're back on this on Endor you must
acquit all evidence that is admitted at
trial must be relevant look at me I'm a
lawyer defending a major record company
and I'm talking about Chewbacca does
that make sense
if at the time it's offered it is not
yet relevant it can be admitted subject
to connection and if Chewbacca for some
reason later in the trial became
relevant why am I talking about
Chewbacca when a man's life is on the
line it could at that time be introduced
even though he had already displayed it
and offered it subject to later
connection the defense rests
oh okay then Wow he's kid representing
yourself fracture mr. Crawford you have
been charged of section 6 64 slash 187
of the California Penal Code attempted
murder do you wish to enter a plea at
this time there's not but I also want to
wait
to console and represent myself in order
for someone to be permitted to represent
themselves they'll be questioned about
whether or not they're doing so
knowingly you wear that lack of counsel
will not be grounds for an appeal
I understand whether they understand the
extent to which they're giving up the
expertise of an attorney
Your Honor if I could have a moment with
my client not you can join people you
and generally speaking they will be
assigned backup counsel to assist and
answer questions as they proceed with
their own defense
mr. Crawford you want to reconsider
absolutely not it's gonna turn into a
circus I appreciate your concern to the
court double-oh-seven
it could be argued that the courtroom is
one of the last bastions of formality in
modern American life but even there a
coat entails is a little bit too much
however I was surprised to hear the
judge refer to the DA as double-oh-seven
87 usually that kind of joking
commentary is reserved for off the
record district attorney's office will
assign another prosecutor no I like mr.
Beecham while the defendant here has an
absolute right to represent himself he
doesn't have the right to choose who the
prosecutor is on his case he likes you
personal digs Boston Legal what better
to satiate some pre-election hunger
pangs than a belly full of media
attention mr. district attorney my name
is Pierre second on the ballot this
November Ginsburg knows that that's why
he's handling this case personally
ouch closing statements are reserved for
the facts and the law outside politics
have no place in either party's closing
statements he was starving
[Music]
when was the last time you starved I'm
bow to you I know you're not starving
except for a denture all of this lawyers
inquiry about collateral issues like
whether the jurors themselves have
starved and what the status of the
district attorney's future election is
are entirely impermissible in court and
the opposing counsel should have been on
his feet objecting and the judge should
have been sustaining all those
objections it makes for great TV but
it's not realistic tampering with the
evidence Chicago mr. Kelly do you know
the meaning of the word perjury you also
know the crime it turns out that you
knew that this Diary was a fake keep
thinking you rotting away in prison for
the next 10 years the lawyer is trying
to accuse the other lawyer of having
tampered with the evidence you're not
suggesting that I tampered with evidence
I save it for summation richard gere the
appropriate way to do that would be for
him to elicit the relevant facts from
witnesses on the stand any idea who this
mysterious benefactor might be know
introduce the relevant material evidence
into evidence and then on summation
explain his theory to the jury not to do
it while there's a witness on the stand
the defense rests
summation the People vs Larry Flynt I'm
not trying to convince you that you
should like what Larry Flynt does I
don't like what Larry Flynt does but
what I do like is that I live in a
country where you and I can make that
decision for ourselves but then ask
yourselves if you want to make that
decision for the rest of us because the
freedom that everyone in this room
enjoys objection up until this point
Edward Norton is totally appropriately
talking to the jury about the context of
the case we live in a free country you
and I can make that decision for
ourselves but once he starts suggesting
that the jury should have a role in
setting policy for everyone and thinking
about how this plays into the future of
the country ask yourselves if you want
to make that
decision for the rest of us he's
stepping beyond the bounds of an
appropriate closing statement that's not
freedom the American legal system is
incredibly complex and no TV show or
movie gets it exactly right that said
it's a lot of fun to watch them try
[Applause]